hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again it's my little movie review show
we have sort of an unusual entry today
i had been curious about seeing this
movie since i saw it mentioned i believe
it was in a documentary called not quite
hollywood
which is about uh australian cinema the
australian new wave ozbloidation all
that you know mad max all that kind of
stuff
um and i really enjoyed that a lot and
they talked about this movie that came
out in 1971 and was called wake in
fright
and as i said i kind of got curious
about seeing it but then i sort of
forgot about it until a couple weeks
back when i was scrolling through 2b and
i noticed that they had it on there for
free so i decided i was going to add it
to the lineup
this movie this is really unusual
because i see it build as a horror film
sometimes
sometimes it's billed as psychological
thriller which is closer it's horror in
the sense that it's kind of horrific and
nightmarish and has like a little bit of
a surreal aspect to it as well even
though it's very grounded in reality but
all of the horror is
human horror there aren't any monsters
or anything like that
now this film interestingly as well
first premiered at cannes i believe
and was a huge hit there and actually
that was the same year that uh nicholas
roig's walkabout uh came out as well and
they were both screened those were like
the big australian movies that screened
that year and it got like all kinds of
like accolades and interestingly though
the movie awakened fright uh while quite
critically successful across the board
particularly in the uk and in france
uh in australia they didn't like it so
much and a lot of people thought maybe
it's because it's kind of showing not
all australians obviously but it's
showing like a particular kind of uh
outback or very very small town
australian in a not really all that
flattering light um and maybe that's
maybe that's not why but many people
have speculated maybe that's why it
didn't do all that well in uh australia
now this movie was actually based on a
book that came out in 1961
of the same title it was directed by ted
kotchev who would actually go on later
to do fun with dick and jane he also did
uh first blood you know the first
rainbow movie and uh later he would do
weekend at bernie's oh i think he just
did that for the paycheck which you know
no shame everybody's got to eat uh but
yeah so it's interesting how his uh this
is the same guy because really none of
those movies this is kind of like first
blood i will say
this movie
it's very very
australian it is perhaps one of and some
uh critics have called it the greatest
australian film ever made uh nick cave
who i'm a big fan of uh famously said
this was you know
something like this is the most
terrifying and accurate like view of
australia ever put to film or something
like that so it's kind of one of those
very sun-drenched bleak deserty
grimy like one of those kind of with
these big sweeping vistas of
dust and sand and it's like everyone's
drunk and it's just kind of like it's
that kind of thing you know it obviously
has analogs in a bunch of other
australian films particularly from this
time period from uh from the australian
new wave which this is actually
considered a part of although it's has a
little bit of the osploitation cycle in
it too because it's like a little bit
it's not trashy but
it has like a lot of more lurid kind of
things going on in it the movie this
reminded me of the most was actually
straw dogs uh sam peck and paw's film uh
just in the sense that
it's kind of critiquing
this particular kind of like overt like
toxic masculinity type of thing but in a
way that it's kind of like a descent
into hell sort of narrative
now
i went into this movie not knowing
exactly what it was about like just
having heard people like martin scorsese
and stuff like that who's also a big
advocate for the film big fan of it
and people saying it was just like
really disturbing and stuff like that
which it is but i purposely didn't
really read anything about what it was
about pretty much all i knew was about
the guy goes to this like outback town
and all this crazy [ __ ] happens um and
that's true as far as it goes but
there are a lot of stuff so i had no
idea like where this was going
now i will say before you run and watch
it because like i said as of this
recording it is on to be for free
because that's where i watched it there
is a scene which is very very
controversial and very
well known very infamous known as the
kangaroo hunt scene
and before you ask yes the kangaroos
that were shot
in this scene
were actually shot in real life they
weren't
reportedly they were not shot
specifically for the movie um which
would be horrible
but basically the filmmakers
went along with a
kangaroo hunt that was going to go on
anyway like with some professional
hunters they were culling uh the
kangaroo population at the time and they
filmed that and then kind of like
interspersed it with you know the
characters going on a kangaroo hunt but
i will say that
most of the kangaroos that get shot in
this and like you see it because i was
watching it and before like i said i
didn't read anything about it before i
watched the movie so when i was watching
the movie i got to that scene and i was
like obviously getting like really
distressed because you know i love
animals i know that kangaroos have to be
called like you know particularly at
this uh time because they would you know
their population's explosion and stuff
like that but
i was kind of i was like horrified and i
was just kind of like looking at going
please please tell me that that is not
real i was like that really looks real
and it's really really bothering me i'm
like i have no idea like how they could
have faked that um but please tell me it
is fake but then when i was like
researching it later it's like that it
wasn't fake it was like a real like the
um there are some parts where like some
of the characters in the movie are like
you know wrestling
one of them and like you know stabbing
him and stuff that's not real but all
the cat all the shots of like the
kangaroos being shot like from you know
those are absolutely real so
know that going in if you don't want to
see that because it is
unpleasant and like i said this is a
kangaroo hunt that would have happened
anyway because these were professional
hunters and apparently the filmmakers
wanted this particular scene in there
and so they followed the hunters and
filmed the hunters doing their thing and
then interspersed it with the actors to
make it look like they were doing it but
your mileage may vary i'm just kind of
like i'm not really i don't know if i
would have watched it knowing that that
was in there it's a great movie i'm not
saying that but that part like like i
said i love animals kangaroos are super
cute and it's just like
not really sure it needed to be i needed
to see like a bunch of them get shot
horribly it was just you know it was
pretty [ __ ] up because it was a hunt
that would have happened anyway it's not
something like cannibal holocaust where
they actually did kill like the big
tortoise and stuff like that for the
movie specifically some people compare
it to you know the ox or the buffalo or
whatever that gets uh slaughtered in
apocalypse now it's kind of like that
which that was real too
so you know it's kind of like a i don't
know it's kind of like a gray area um
like i said i don't know if i would have
watched this movie knowing that that was
in there because that kind of stuff like
really upsets me it's [ __ ] even like
seeing fake animal cruelty in movies is
like really upsetting so seeing like
real kangaroos get shot um you know was
not a good time but i persevered and
like i said this is actually a great
movie like a classic of australian
cinema one interesting thing about this
i don't know if they mentioned this in
the not quite hollywood
documentary but for a long time this
movie was considered like the great lost
film of australian cinema because i
guess like the main like the the main
negative
of it had vanished like nobody knew what
happened to it or it got destroyed or
something like that so for a long time
all that remained of this movie was just
like shitty copies that weren't even
like good enough to like put out on tv
or vhs like they i think they did do a
couple like real cheap ass like vhs
releases and stuff maybe like in the 70s
or 80s but
they looked like really really crap and
as i said for a long time they thought
like the actual
original negative was gone but then in
2004 i think somebody actually found it
they were looking for it so they did
like a bunch of uh research and they
actually did find a pristine original
negative
and so the movie was painstakingly
restored and then they uh they did like
a worldwide screening they they did
another screening for it at can so
everybody got to come see it that hadn't
been able to see it for many many years
in the form that it was uh intended so
there's that as well and i think it's
got like a lot more appreciation since
then and like i said now it's had like a
blu-ray release and it's on to be it's
on all these other streaming services as
well
so what is this movie about jenny you
might be asking
as i said it's based on a book that came
out in 1961 uh by kenneth cook
and
it is about something but i will say
okay
this is
the sweatiest
drunkest
like
dirtiest nastiest grimiest movie i think
i've ever watched it's just like every
i mean the cinematography is beautiful
um but you know it's australian outback
so everything's just very yellow and
sand and rocks and it's just kind of
like these shitty structures there's
like these tiny little towns out in the
middle of nowhere and it's the middle of
summer
when they're fixed so everything is just
like hazy and wavy everybody is just
like damp and shiny and just like
covered with sweat there's flies all
over everything everything's dirty and
like covered with sand and gross and
everyone's clothes are sweaty and dirty
and it's just it's just nasty it's just
you could smell it you could smell the
movie like through the [ __ ] screen or
at least i could because the thing about
it because you know i grew up in florida
which you know it's
it's not the climate's obviously not the
same as the australian outback we have
the heat but our heat's like swampy heat
whereas theirs is like desert heat um so
i get it like i get like everybody
walking around just looking like their
[ __ ] faces or melting off because
it's everyone's just like sweating their
balls off so
i could kind of like relate to them like
holy [ __ ] like this really looks like i
can imagine what it must have smelled
like to film some of those seeds it's
like everything's just like disgusting
everything's disgusting everybody is
perpetually drunk everybody's just like
perpetually like obnoxious and it's just
kind of like like i said it's almost
like this nightmarish experience that
like a descent into hell or something
like that
so here's the story uh you have a guy
named john grant and he is a school
teacher now apparently back when this
movie was made or back when the novel
was written i'm not sure what the law is
like now or what the [ __ ] is like now
but what they would do was i guess they
didn't have enough teachers for kind of
these public schools sort of out in the
outback right
so they would have this deal where
you would kind of like pay this bond or
they would pay for you to
you know get your teaching certificate
or whatever if you would agree to like a
two-year contract
at some school out in the like the ass
end of nowhere
so that's apparently what this john
grant guy has done he's this very middle
class educated type of dude um and you
can tell that he really really does not
like living out here in the middle of
but [ __ ] nowhere but you know he's got
to do his contract and that's kind of
what he agreed to and he's kind of like
a little bit resentful about it
so he's so the town that he lives in is
called taboonda and it's basically kind
of like
back in the old days you know like back
in the frontier days of the united
states when they had a one-room
schoolhouse and like everybody every kid
it didn't matter what age they were was
like in the same class that's what this
is so there's just like everybody from
like four or five year olds to like 18
19 year olds like in this [ __ ] one
room
class so at the very beginning he's
sitting there looking at him everybody's
kind of like waiting you know for their
watch or everything like that and it's
the christmas holidays now like i said
this is the southern hemisphere so
christmas is right in the bang on in the
middle of summer so again it's like hot
sunny sandy whatever
so john grant has planned to go to
sydney to see his girlfriend
and he's really really happy to be
getting the [ __ ] out of tobunda
now
i guess like
to go to
to get where his flight to sydney is he
has to go through this mining town
called bundanyaba
uh which the locals call the yabba
that's basically what they call it uh
you're not from the yabba that's like
they all kind of say so he ends up there
and uh that's where he's gonna get
transport for his you know flight out to
sydney or whatever or when he's going to
the airport i don't know i don't know
how it works out i don't know where the
closest airport is
so while he's waiting for his
transportation in the yabba
uh he decides he's gonna go you know
have a pint as one does
now he goes in this
bar which is actually kind of like it's
not it's kind of like a bar but it's
actually kind of like this big huge like
rec center more like
and the whole place is full of dudes i
just there's no women in there and it's
just all dudes and like most and they're
all sweaty so it's like all these sweaty
dudes some of them have their shirts off
and stuff like that because it's like 4
million degrees outside it looks like
and you know the place is just like
[ __ ] packed to the rafters because
you know it's
one of the days before christmas
holidays so everyone's kind of like
celebrating i guess
so he goes in there and it's just like
[ __ ] wall-to-wall people
now he meets up with this guy named jack
crawford who is
uh the cop in the yabba
and this guy
i kind of liked not knowing where this
was going because
the guy is that's the thing that's so
like creepy and insidious about like i
said this isn't a horror movie
necessarily
but
it has like some ear like some
unsettling it's more like unsettling
than anything else because you're not
entirely sure
what's gonna happen in any given
situation you know i mean everything
just seems like it's slightly on edge or
like slightly off kilter it just kind of
seems like that the whole time
so he meets the cop
crawford and at him and everybody in the
town
they're not
hostile like obviously they know that
he's not from there because they know
everybody and he looks like better
dressed than them he's not quite as
sweaty he's not quite as inebriated you
know so he looks like he kind of has his
[ __ ] together so everybody's like
friendly
but they're friendly in that really like
aggressive kind of way
you know how like in rosemary's baby
like you know how the cast of vets were
like friendly but
obnoxiously so like so much that they
were just like overly they were like
always like suffocating you and like up
in your face that's kind of like what
these dudes are like where it seems like
it's friendly but it's still kind of
like sinister or kind of threatening at
the same time but you don't necessarily
know
how the shit's gonna go like they seem
like they're being nice they're buying
you drinks and they're doing this and
that but then if you don't do [ __ ] quite
the way they want you to then you kind
of have a feeling that shit's going to
go sideways like pretty quick so like i
said there's kind of like this whole
tension the whole time that where you
don't really know like how they're going
to react like if you don't want to do
something that they want you to do you
know what i mean
so the cop comes in there and he's kind
of like telling about you know oh the
yabba this is the best place ever maybe
you can come here on your vacation
because he says yeah i'm just stopping
here for a night like i gotta go to
sydney in the morning i'm gonna see my
girlfriend blah blah he's gonna spend
like six weeks there and i was like do
they really get six weeks for christmas
vacation in [ __ ]
australia holy [ __ ] i need to [ __ ]
move there i the most i ever got at work
was a week and that was even that was
unusual
um school kids get two weeks but i never
heard of nobody get in six weeks before
that's [ __ ] awesome but yeah i don't
know but he but he was like i'll see you
in six weeks you know so i guess it was
six weeks i was like wow that must be
nice
be nice i need to move somewhere they
have actual vacations they don't give me
vacations here uh but yeah or they do
but they're like super super short
so yeah so uh so this guy the cop this
is what i mean like he keeps buying him
booze
but like he'll buy him a beer he buys
him a beer and then like he's still got
one because he's just like sipping it
like a normal ass person and then he's
like well you know i'll buy you a beer
and he's like no i got one and he's like
well finish that one up and i'll buy you
another one and he's like
okay so he like [ __ ] chugs it and
then the guy takes the glasses and go
over there so and then every time like
he brings him another one like he like
looks at him until he [ __ ] drinks it
so he can you know what i mean it's kind
of like finish your beer so you can have
another beer type of situation oh by the
way do not
repeat do not make a drinking game out
of this movie you will be dead in 20
minutes if you try to match
the amount of drinking that the people
do in this movie i've seen people drink
this much before like in one day like
over the course of a day like this and
they're drinking beer it's not like it's
i mean some of them drink like shots of
whiskey or something like that but it's
mostly beer so i've seen people drink
that much but it's just kind of like how
i don't understand how they could still
be like walking around i just really
don't but yeah seriously do not don't
try to match like the the drinking in
this because all the people do here is
drink they just drink and drink and
drink and like i said it's just kind of
like they get a beer and then they chug
it and then they go get another one like
immediately you know what i mean they
gotta finish that beer so they can move
on to the next one and that's just kind
of what they do in this town that's
pretty much all there is to do so the
cop keeps doing that and like i said
he's not being aggressive he's not being
hostile he's actually being kind of
friendly hey i'll show you around the
town hey i'll introduce you to some
people and john's kind of like
not really having it because the thing
about john is that in some ways
justifiably you know he's from a big
city he's uh you know a lot more
educated things like that so he kind of
like looks down his nose at some of
these people and like i said
you know you could call him a snob and
stuff like that but the way that [ __ ]
goes in a way i think he's kind of like
justified in feeling that the people
here are just like these [ __ ]
animalistic
useless drunken louts that just like do
nothing but like fight and you know
sponge off of people and it's just kind
of like so i can see why he's kind of
snotty about it the only mistake i think
he makes is that being rather open about
his contempt of these kind of like small
town people like what the [ __ ] are they
even doing with their life um and part
of that might stem from his own
resentment because he doesn't like that
he's stuck in some like
butthole little town and he kind of
wants to go he actually wants to go not
even back to sydney he wants to move to
england uh with his girlfriend so that's
kind of his aspiration
uh so yeah so he's like not real
he's not real magnanimous like he's not
and he's not really willing to keep his
mouth shut so he's a little bit of a
snot
and
like i said the cop doesn't really get
offended but he's just kind of like he
can't believe like why anybody would not
like this town this is the yabba it's
the best place ever why would you want
to go anyplace else even though it's
clearly not the best place ever it's a
[ __ ] um by pretty much any measure
so uh so yeah so as this goes on like
obviously he keeps buying more and more
beers john doesn't really have the
stones to like kind of stand up and be
like hey i don't really want anymore or
if you do like you can say that but then
everybody will kind of get all aggro and
then they'll sort of like
bully you into
keeping drinking you know what i mean so
there's that so he ends up getting like
pretty [ __ ] plastered
and uh the cop takes him over this other
place like to get him some food like to
get him some steak or whatever and in
the back room of this restaurant there
is like this big like gambling thing
and it's basically i didn't know if it
was i didn't know if it was a real game
or not i mean i figured it probably was
but it's called two up and it's just
kind of like two quarters or whatever
and somebody puts them on a
like a little piece of stick or like a
little something and then you flip them
up in the air and then if they both land
heads or they both land tails then
whoever bet on either one of those
things wins if one of them's heads and
one of them tails then nobody wins they
just do it again
so he's kind of curious and he goes back
there in the back room and there's like
all these dudes like sweaty smelly
dudes like back there betting on this
game
and at first he's just kind of like
that's some stupid [ __ ] and i was like
yeah i agree
but the drunker he gets and while he's
in this cafe also he meets donald
pleasance's character because donald
pleasance is in this in case i didn't
mention it uh donald pleasence is almost
kind of like
the dark side of john grant's character
because he's a doctor he's educated he's
from the big city but then he came to
the yabba
and he just kind of like succumbed
to to the madness he succumbed to the
shittiness of the place
and he's kind of like
picking on john a little bit for being
so contemptuous of them he's like oh
what do you expect him to do like sing
opera or anything like that it's like
they don't have anything and he says
something like
you know uh if you're stuck somewhere
you might as well like it
so apparently that's what happened
because doc is also an alcoholic
although i don't know how you could tell
he was an alcoholic any more than
anybody else in this movie because
everybody in this constantly drinks i
mean that's all they do is drink so i
don't really know how he's more
alcoholic than anybody else but he's the
only one that's willing to admit to
himself that he's an alcoholic i guess
so there's that uh so he gets in a
conversation with that guy so then like
he but then like as more he gets drunk
and the more he kind of thinks about
what uh donald pleasant said
he kind of like goes back in the you
know in the room and he's like oh what
the [ __ ] i'm gonna put some money down
on uh you know on this game
and he does and he ends up he does it a
couple times and he ends up winning a
whole bunch of money
and he's just kind of like oh awesome
now he wins a whole bunch of money and
like a smart person
he goes back to his hotel room and it's
like woo look at all this [ __ ] money
and then
like a not so smart person he thinks to
himself you know
if i took all of this
every gambler in the world
if i took all of this money
all i have to do is just win one more
coin flip and i will have enough money
to get the [ __ ] out of my contract and
move to england with my girlfriend i can
be out of this i can be out of this
so stupidly he decides to do that
it will surprise nobody
that
he ends up
losing all of his money
all of it
so
he's basically stuck in this town
because like i said he was supposed to
leave and he had quite a bit of money on
him
and like a dumbass uh he lost every
single [ __ ] penny of it i think he
had like a buck left or something
so now he's stuck in this town
and
the more he's stuck there
the more
his morality i guess starts to degrade
to a point where he just starts hanging
out with all of these
bums that just kind of like they're just
these obnoxious
like super like
macho like that's all they want to do is
like sit around and drink and they don't
give a [ __ ] about anything else but
drinking and like shooting kangaroos and
like
throwing [ __ ] at
like doing [ __ ] petty crimes and
fighting one another and just that and
gambling that's all they do none of them
have jobs none of them do anything
remotely uh useful they all just kind of
like lay around and this whole town it
seems has almost kind of like
become
a little bit
it's like nobody seems to do anything
like nobody has like you know except for
the guy that like works in the cafe and
like cooks and stuff it's like everybody
just seems to like sit around and
everyone just kind of like sponges off
everybody else
and one of the things that doc or donald
pleasance like says to the guy is like
oh well if you're in the yabba and you
don't have any money like everybody will
just give you free [ __ ] like everybody
will just buy you free beer and stuff
like that which
sounds neat until you think that maybe
the reason they're doing that is because
they're just trying to drag everybody
else down to the same level with them so
that's essentially what happens this
dumb
john grant like i said okay i do like
his character but a few times
like i said when he's doing the gambling
thing look i you know i've been really
drunk i've done stupid [ __ ] too it's
like i could see that one thing
but as it goes on and he's just starts
hanging out with these people
and like i said this is almost kind of
like hanging out with obnoxious drunks
the movie which is like a nightmare
which to me was something that made it
like really nightmarish because it's
really like i said there's you know this
is the australian outback but there are
still like some kind of uh you know
analogs in kind of like you know
rednecks sort of culture and it's just
sort of like
yeah like hanging out with drunk ass
people like that all day is like one of
my worst nightmares because i grew up
kind of in a red ecky kind of town and
it's like i just i hate that whole
mindset i hate that whole thing but the
fact that
he was supposedly so
educated you know he has like his a
couple of his uh suitcases and he has
books about you know plato and socrates
and stuff and doc even like calls him
socrates like jokingly so it's that kind
of thing because they think oh he's just
like some useless intellectual and blah
blah but then as he just starts hanging
out with these people
it's like at first he's kind of like
offended or contemptuous or whatever but
then
it seems like really quickly he kind of
just gets sucked into this morass of
as i said just kind of like hanging out
just being filthy and dirty and going
out like i said and hunting kangaroos
like from a [ __ ] car and just you
know just picking them off from the car
like in the headlights and you know he
even they even like have him go and like
wrestle one and like stab it like to
show his manhood and all this other kind
of [ __ ] so it's just that kind of thing
and then like even more [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happens later like he ends up meeting
kind of uh this woman named jeanette who
you know seems like she wants to get out
of there too but then they find out
later that she's kind of like the town
[ __ ] she's kind of like banged everybody
and
then like he ends up over at doc's house
like after one night where he drank so
much that he blacked out and nobody
remembers anything and daca is just like
it lives in this like disgusting [ __ ]
hole of a shack and he's like you know
he doesn't pay for anything and he's
just makes it like this weird gross stew
like out of kangaroo meat and he has to
keep doing the flies off of it it's so
gross it's so gross and uh and then like
if like basically like um i think it's
implied
that doc
either
rapes him or tried to rape him like
while he was really drunk that's very
very strongly implied
so you know after all this happens the
[ __ ] up thing is like so all this [ __ ]
happens john is there
for
well i think he ends up he's there for
like four days because at first like
when he loses all his money
the next day he actually tries to do
something to correct it as in you know
i'll go to the labor office and i'll
just get like a short like a job so i
can get some money just so i can get out
of town you know what i mean until i can
access the rest of my money or whatever
so he does try to do that but then like
he does it it's a saturday the office is
closed and then he just ends up in this
bar and it just becomes like this
[ __ ]
spiraled down downward like from then on
uh where like i said that he's just
ended up shooting kangaroos and you know
getting possibly raped by donald
pleasance and all kinds of terrible
things happening and then like the way i
don't know if i really want to spoil the
end because i kind of feel like maybe a
lot of people haven't seen this it's a
little bit i kind of feel like it's
slightly more obscure as i said i had
only heard about it because it was
mentioned on that
australian uh film documentary and it
just kind of sounded sort of interesting
to me yeah i mean it ends up it's it's
kind of like the way that it ends up is
sort of like all this [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happens like a really [ __ ] up thing
happens after that but then
you know he sort of like gets out of it
and he gets and he just goes back to he
doesn't go to sydney he just goes to
like to bunda and he's somebody asked
him like hey hey how was your holiday
he's like oh it was the best i'm like
okay
whatever so it's always just kind of
like
he went through the it's like a trial by
fire thing like i said i guess they were
trying to make a point about this kind
of like
weird like like overly toxic masculinity
kind of thing but how it was like a rite
of passage or something and like now
he's learned something new about himself
or whatever but yeah so you have to go
be like a scuzzy drunk
in the australian outback and shoot
little innocent animals from a car
and then like just and fight with your
friends and throw bottles at a bar and
[ __ ] like that just i'm like okay
whatever you do you bro
that's what that's what you want to do
then all right but yeah so uh yeah this
movie is on
to be at the moment as i said don't go
into it expecting like a traditional
horror movie it's very australian it's
very it's like australian new wave meets
a little bit of exploitation so you have
those like i said those big desert
vistas like these old crumbly type of
stores like everything looks like it's
grimy and covered with sand and
everybody's sweaty and it's just kind of
like and everybody's just drunk the
entire time and everybody's gross and
uh you know and dirty and it's just kind
of that and it's just
it's more like a psychological and it's
not like a lot of the um
imagery isn't necessarily surreal it
does have a couple little things where
it kind of goes like woo like when he
gets like super drunk and everything
which makes it but it's almost kind of
like it's a very sunlit
deserty
like wavy sunlight kind of like
nightmare so it's that kind of thing uh
if that sounds like something that you
would be into if you like australian
films from that era
then i would absolutely recommend
checking it out i found it really really
uh compelling some people i saw a couple
reviewers that didn't like it they just
thought it was
boring because they thought it was just
a guy hanging around with a bunch of uh
[ __ ] drunks all the time that are
like always shouting and smacking each
other and drinking
which
you know i could see that i get it but
um i kind of think the point of the
story was the way he just kind of got
sucked into the culture of this place
and how easy it was for somebody who was
supposedly better than that to kind of
like just
revert to the mean i guess so uh and how
easy that was so i think that was kind
of like the point of the movie how easy
it was for him to like revert to
savagery like even though he was
supposedly uh so enlightened and whatnot
so you know so kind of but no going in
uh the kangaroo hunt scene
is which is probably about three
quarters of the way through if i'm not
uh if i'm not mistaken
is pretty upsetting to watch because
like i said those kangaroos did actually
get shot for real um so if that's not
really something you want to watch
maybe kind of skip it it's not like the
whole movie it's probably only like i
don't know it's like a five or ten
minute scene something like that but
it's uh it's pretty infamous for a
reason apparently the director who but
he was a vegetarian i don't know if he
still is i don't even know if he's still
alive at this point but um he kind of
justified it he said look i i went
through he's like i was gonna cut it out
and then i went to like all the animal
cruelty things and they said no you
should absolutely show it because we
want people to see how horrifying that
is and so it's better not to sugarcoat
it which i can see that argument
uh so yeah but just know it was very
very uh distressing for me to watch uh
and you know because you know how i am
about animals like i said even
fake animal cruelty in movies
really really bothers me and
i was watching this and being like man
please tell me that's fake that looks
really real and then like afterward i
was like [ __ ] it is real oh i knew it i
knew it i just knew it wasn't fake i
could tell so know that going in but
other than that uh if you're really into
australian cinema from this uh time
period from the early 1970s then it's
definitely definitely worth checking out
has like 96 or rotten tomatoes or
something like that as i said it's kind
of more like a psychological
film there's no supernatural anything
nothing like that it's more just kind of
like a nightmare so if you've seen it
let me know what you think about it in
the comments or if it sounds interesting
uh you know we can talk about that too
and that'll do it for this flickers fear
i will see you guys on the next one bye